Welcome to the MIT Center for
Art, Science & Technology's
2021 Symposium
"Unfolding Intelligence:
the Art and Science of
Contemporary Computation".
CAST was established
in 2012 with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
that CAST has
convened since then.
And as with its predecessors,
we bring together
artists, scientists, engineers,
and humanists from within MIT
and from the world
at large to discuss
areas of
rapidly-evolving research
and urgent social relevance.
And to find, in that dialogue,
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and, we hope, common purpose.
At MIT, CAST partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum,
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration, and to provide
support to faculty and
members of the MIT community
as they pursue their
own artistic practice
and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAST facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications, and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to
seeing you on Friday,
April 9th as the
symposium culminates
with a live interactive
event to which
all attendees are invited.
And which you can join
presenters and artists
in breakout rooms to explore
hidden threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
Hi, I'm very glad
to be with you today
to talk about the "Generative
Unfoldings" exhibit.
I'm Nick Montfort, and
I want to introduce
my colleague, Fox
Harrell from MIT here;
Lauren Lee McCarthy, from UCLA;
and Sarah Rosalena Brady,
from UC-Santa Barbara.
Also, I want to extend
thanks to Parag Mital, who
couldn't be with us for
this conversation today.
But all of us participated
in the conversation
about how to select works for
commissions for this project.
And this project
manifests itself
as a generative art exhibit with
works running in the browser,
but also is a free
software exhibit
that allows people to
study, fork, distribute,
rework any of the projects
that have been done in it.
And this is all
thanks to the Center
for Art, Science, and
Technology here at MIT.
And in relation to
the generative--
this "Generative
Unfoldings" exhibit
is in relation to the "Unfolding
Intelligence" symposium.
We weren't able to
do what we've done
in the past with symposia--
bring people physically
to campus, have panels and
good in-person engagement.
So we decided to reach out
to the community of artists
and bring some of
their work online
in ways that it could
live in the browser
and run in the browser.
But it could also be part
of future collaborations
and work with projects
of generative sorts.
So maybe the best question
to start off with in relation
to the artworks themselves, the
commissions that we awarded,
and the pieces that
we ended up with here,
is about what generative
art exactly is,
because I think
there's a stereotype
or a concept of generative art.
It's a new concept that we have.
It's not like painting or
sculpture that's been around
with us for centuries.
But there's already some
type of typical idea
of what generative art is.
And one of the things that
excites me about the show
is that it's certainly not
unrelated to that idea.
But I think there's a lot
of interesting variation
and diversity in the
works that we see.
Maybe I'll ask
Lauren if you'd like
to talk about what generative
art maybe has been more
typically or has been
thought of and if you
see trends in the
show that challenge
or expand that in
some interesting ways.
Sure.
I mean, I think generative
art in the most basic sense
could be thought of as
art that's made with code
and that is constantly
generating or constantly making
a new form with itself.
So it's different than
a video or an image,
where it's a closed work
that you could loop or view
multiple times, but it
always stays the same.
so with a generative
work, there's
a quality of liveness,
where it's always changing.
And often, you might
see an iteration
that's never been seen before
in the playthrough of the work,
because it's live
running software.
However, I think
that in the past
that our conception of what
might fit into generative art
has been more limited in terms
of the sorts of aesthetics
that we're seeing,
or the
types of moves or
techniques used with code.
And I think what's
interesting about this--
and often, it's focused a lot
on the very visual, formal realm
of things.
And I think what's
really exciting
about this exhibition
is that it really
spans a wide range of
media and techniques.
And it's hard to find works
that actually even look
very similar to each other.
They all go in really
different directions.
Yeah, that's definitely one
of the things that I noticed.
And in fact, from
my own standpoint,
as someone who has
a practice as a poet
and is involved with text
and language particularly,
it's interesting.
Maybe I just attracted
those types of submissions.
Or maybe that was
something that came out
of my being part of the
conversation and so forth.
But there's nine works
by my count, where text
is a really important aspect--
about nine of the 14.
And that is compatible
with an idea
of generative art,
obviously, but not something
that we imagine in maybe the
stereotypical geometric play
of shapes running by themselves.
And I should say also,
speaking of things
that run by themselves, that's
an idea that is not absolutely
defining in generative art.
But I recently was teaching
from Margaret Boden
and Ernest Edmonds'
book, Fingers to Digits,
and they defined this
concept of CG art,
giving everything a
name in the typology.
And so this is what we really
mean by "generative art" here.
And the standard
central example of that
is stuff that runs by itself.
So they don't preclude
things that are interactive.
But you really
should-- the piece
should really run by itself
if it really definitely wants
to be generative art.
And so we also have lots of
stuff that's interactive.
And that's interesting
to me that there
are some things where
interactivity is optional.
There are some things,
though, that do run, but allow
for intervention.
Did you want to
make any comments,
say, Fox, about that aspect or
another aspect of the artworks
themselves in the exhibit?
Yeah
I think that
both Lauren and you have made
made such great points here.
One of the things that
I can add, in addition to
the computer-generated
aspect of this kind of work,
is looking at it in
art historical context.
So for me, it relates
not only to works
that run autonomously
or computationally,
but also trends in other forms
of art, such as conceptual art,
where forms of conceptual
art, such as instruction art,
works within literary practice
such as from the group
Oulipo doing experimental
role-constrained work and more.
And so when I think
back to conceptual and
instruction-based artwork,
I see a similar kind
of difference, where
you have some works that
are very formally focused.
Like Sol LeWitt's
work, for example,
tends to be highly formal.
But you also have artists such
as Adrian Piper or Yoko Ono
that do work that, in one
case, is more politically
engaged and socially engaged.
In another case,
I would say it's
more politically and
socially engaged,
too, in terms of
say, Yoko Ono's instruction
art for paintings-- that,
"Cut a hole in a canvas.
Hold it up to a sky"--
this kind of work.
And so I think the
idea of instructions
that will be used to
generate some work,
whether they're actually
implemented or just conceptual,
I think is quite related to
this kind of show and this idea
that we have artists that
work in a poetic vein,
in a sociopolitical
vein, and more, using
instruction-based or
algorithmic techniques
is something that's unique
about this particular show.
I should say, at least,
it's underrepresented
when compared to a lot
of generative artwork
that tends to be more
formally focused.
Yeah, I think there's a
range of work, some of which
is quite overtly engaged with
the power and susceptibility
of the gaze with
surveillance, even
with self-doubting
and questioning
and things like this.
And other pieces that complicate
the highly formalist sorts
of projects of generative art--
those are a few of the
trends that I noticed
in the artwork that
maybe make this different
than the overall stereotype.
Sarah, do you want to add to
that from your perspective
in terms of how the
artworks look to you?
Yeah, no, and I
completely agree with Fox.
A lot of relationship
between Dada and Fluxus
and how a lot of the
works that we chose
include this formal instruction
as a way to produce.
But because we're looking
at this in the future
and also focusing more on the
terms of AI, a lot of this
is pointed towards language
and decision-making
towards the unknown, which
I think is so interesting.
This idea of generative art
or "generative unfoldings"
is how these works
also try to understand
what's hidden because what their
output is an emergent form.
And I find that is
really important when
we have these really complex
conversations about how
these artworks are going
to be shaping our future
and how it could
be more inclusive.
And that, again, goes back
to this lineage of how
this idea of this output
of something emergent
is really unique and special
because it can really
get to the core root of what we
don't see and what is unknown,
and also have the unknown
and things that are alien
have power.
And I'm curious what
you guys think, too.
Yeah, I mean-- go
ahead, Lauren, please.
Yeah, I would just
want to add I think
one thing I noticed with the
exhibition, the selected works,
was that we're talking about
these generative systems, which
is software.
But the human is really
present in a lot of the pieces.
And Nick, you were mentioning
the language coming through.
[00:10:31.42] And I
think that for me,
that reads as a part of it.
There's a real
questioning of, OK,
so we have these
systems around us.
How do we interact
with them as humans?
How are they shaping
us as society?
In what ways is that
moving us towards a future
that we do or don't want to see,
to speak to Sarah's point, too.
Yeah.
And also-- go ahead,
Fox, actually.
Please.
Oh, I was just going
to add that I've
been long interested in how AI
and other kinds of expressive
systems encode
societies phantasms--
that is, in terms of the
social or the mental,
the sensory imagery,
that we engage
with that encodes worldview
of all different types,
including bias.
And one of the terms that's come
into common parlance these days
is "algorithmic bias."
That's a kind of concern that
we have with AI in general, not
just an anxiety.
It's something that's a real
concern, especially as we've
moved more towards artificial
neural network-based systems
as being prevalent.
So I think that a lot of
what Sarah is speaking about
is about that the kind of
implicit information that gets
built into these
kinds of systems.
But what I love about this
particular set of works
is that it's not only
about those kind of issues
around algorithmic
bias in the abstract.
But it's engaging with notions
such as feminist theory
or notions like the subaltern
and critique of hegemony
from cultural studies and
related kinds of research areas
and representations
and theories of gender
and so much more,
along with the formal.
And so I feel like that's
something which is especially
powerful, is to leverage this
generative algorithmic data
structural kind of approach--
engage deeply with AI,
but for these kind of issues--
feminism, the subaltern, gender,
and identity and society,
politics, and so much more.
Yeah, I think the range
of topics and issues
of cultural relevance that are
taken on is quite impressive,
and also the fact
that these aren't just
works that use a single
artistic method to do AI
to everything in the same way.
They relate to visualizing,
to textualizing, to collaging,
to using a variety of
different processes related
to the way we think
about AI as it
pertains to these other
cultural phenomena.
But maybe we should talk
some about the human beings,
not just the computational
techniques, that
are involved with these
pieces, because they're
made by artists.
And I think we have an
interesting range of artists.
I don't want to be too
quantitative, like we often
are at MIT, and try to list
right now how many countries
and things like that.
But I do think it's
intriguing that we have people
at different stages of their
work, some who are doing really
the first project as an
art duo, some of whom
have quite mature
practices and have
made many different
contributions
in generative art.
We have people associated with
different schools and programs.
And we have people
who come to this
from many, many
different perspectives--
work individually in some cases,
collaborate in other cases.
What do you all think about
the particular set of artists
and artist duos that
we have represented
and that have actually put
together this work that we're
looking at?
Does anyone want to
offer some comments
on the people behind the artwork
and what new sorts of trends
we see there?
One thing that I
was thinking about
was how these works fit into
the practice of the artists.
So I noticed for
some works, this work
that they have in
the exhibition is
part of a long series of works
in this direction that they've
been making.
And then for others, it's
actually a first or one
of the first forays into
generative art or making
something that's primarily
web or software-based,
and maybe coming from a practice
that's more based in sculpture
or video or other media.
So I think that was
really exciting to see.
And I wonder how
much of it also had
to do with the pandemic
in general and the fact
that a lot of artists are
questioning and thinking
about how their practices
live in this virtual space.
But I think because
of that, there
is a really nice energy
here, where there are--
the works are building on
communities or libraries
that exist.
So it's very tied to
longstanding collaborative
traditions in making
generative art.
But there's also this
energy of new exploration
and new experiments
that feels very tangible
in a lot of the works.
Yeah.
Maybe I should also
ask that we say
a little bit about our own
creative practices, which
we all have.
We all come to this as
artists of some sort.
And we also have our academic
affiliations under our belt
and so forth.
And I mentioned that I
do identify as a poet,
and my work is definitely
focused on language.
But for me, even
more computation
is important to what I do.
So creative computing
of various sorts,
often dealing with language,
is central to my approach.
Sarah, will you tell us
about your art practice
and its relationship
to generative art?
Yeah, so I actually teach
computational craft,
which is a really unique
way of deconstructing
and materializing technology.
But I really use it, especially
with AI and all these emergent
forms and making, as a way to
really break down and open up
new systems for
new possibilities
and have new conversations,
just because the historical root
of computation and code,
rooted in the military
and colonialism.
It's really important
that we continue
to have these
conversations and evolve
because these partial
perspectives create
objective vision.
So we need to constantly be
including arts and humanities
and force the machine to
think outside the box.
And I feel like-- like
what Lauren just said.
This is the perfect moment.
I feel like people
are really starting
to be aware of the systems
they participate in because
of the pandemic, because
technology has been
the crucial platform for
this whole perspective,
including us talking over Zoom.
So I think that's
really important
because we are going to have to
break the systems in many ways.
And art has always done that.
And that's why-- because
art and technology really
do co-evolve with each other.
Yes.
And the moment for
this investigation--
it's not just an
opportunity to invite
some artists to put some things
online, although I think it is.
But it is a real
reflective moment
in dealing with
art and computing.
Fox, tell us some
about your engagement
as an artist as well
as your other roles
as a computer
scientist, for instance?
Sure, I'd be happy to.
So I think the way that I
approach this kind of work
is looking at the
computer as a medium,
and then more specifically,
certain types of techniques,
like AI-based techniques--
looking at the way
that meaning is
represented and encoded
within computational systems,
and then leveraging it
for expression, especially
narrative, narrative imagining,
this type of work that
has the kind of coherence
in terms of time, in terms
of causality, and so forth.
But really engaged
with social issues,
with genre and other forms
of fiction at the same time.
And so to make that
more concrete is
to think about ways that, say,
an author in genre fiction
might leverage fantasy or
diverse forms of the imaginary
for social critique
in very precise ways.
And I think about works not in
one particular kind of genre
or one particular
medium, but works
that have that kind of
quality across them.
So that could be work like,
in literature, Ralph Ellison's
Invisible Man, which I
feel is one of the greatest
works of sociology
that just happens
to be in the form of a
highly metaphorical work
of literature.
But also, people like
Italo Calvino, I think,
who uses highly
formal approaches
to get really lush, poetic
kind of prose within the work.
And people like, say, Charles
Mingus or Nina Simone,
that leverage both
compositional strategies along
with political engagement
to make really sometimes
incendiary and incisive
social statements.
So I really look for those
kinds [INAUDIBLE] takes the form
[INAUDIBLE] of their games that
are pushing the expressive
potential of computational
games medium--
sometimes immersive
environments,
such as in virtual reality,
and sometimes novel forms
that incorporate
aspects of all of those,
but might not be
anticipated by just some
of those conventional labels.
Yeah, and when you came to
MIT, the lab you founded
is the Imagination,
Computation, and Expression Lab.
And this idea that computing can
be expressive and imaginative--
can offer the
phantasms that allow
us to work toward
a better society--
is a very compelling one.
A lot of my work is
not so expressive.
It's not much about the
things I wish to express,
but it's more about a conceptual
or cool sort of engagement
with language and
computation, which I hope then
resonates in a really compelling
and interesting way because
of all of the cultural histories
and linguistic histories
and histories of computing that
it can't help but bounce up
against.
But let me give Lauren a
chance to tell us some.
I'm really eager to hear
her speak about her art work
as well.
Sure.
Yeah, my practice is very
grounded in performance
and software.
But it spans a range of media.
And I'm really
captivated by the ways
that we're taught to
interact with algorithms,
and then, by extension, that
shapes the way we interact
with each other.
So very central to
the work is a critique
of the both technical and
social systems that we're
building around
ourselves, and kind
of poking at and questioning,
what are these rules?
What happens when we
introduce glitches?
So to give some
examples, I'm often
creating performances that
have some viewer engagement.
So it's asking people to
remote-control my dates
or offering to be their
real-life follower
or providing a service, where
I am acting in their home
as a human Amazon Alexa.
So I'm making these
performances in which we
both enter into the
system and try to navigate
and understand our
roles within it
and then hopefully,
by extension,
maybe understand some of the
larger systems around us.
And I think each one of
these feels like an attempt--
like I'm trying to
almost embody a machine
or understand the distance
between the algorithm
and myself or the distance
between others and me.
And there are these
breakdowns in that process,
and then just a
lot of questions.
Who builds these
artificial systems,
and what values do they embody?
Who is prioritized,
and who's targeted
as we're talking about biases
programmatically encoded?
And then what are the boundaries
around our intimate spaces?
And in the midst of all
these networked interfaces,
what does it mean to be truly
present with one another?
So those are the questions
I'm thinking about.
But often, there's a high
degree of just awkwardness
and ambiguity in these
moments I'm trying to create.
Yeah.
And, well, I know that one of
the concerns you and I share--
not just you and I, but
I think all four of us--
is that of enabling people
to be creative, conceptual,
imaginative, expressive
with computing.
And we talked about
this in the past.
You don't think of maybe
P5.js the last time we talked.
You didn't think of P5.js as
part of your artistic practice.
But it's a very
significant project
related to generative
art and enabling, really,
of a community of
people online who
are able to exchange and
deal with their work.
And this really leads
on to the last big topic
that I wanted us
to talk about some.
We talked about the
artworks a little bit.
We talked about
artists a little bit.
But there's also these
communities and groups
that this production comes from.
It's not just someone
sitting alone on a computer,
coming up with an idea, and
putting it up on the web.
So can you tell us some?
Doesn't have to be about P5.js
exclusively, but certainly
that's a really
intriguing project
I'd love to hear more about.
Can you tell us some
about these communities
of computational art production
from your perspective, Lauren?
Yeah.
I guess I don't think
of it, like you said,
as [INAUDIBLE]
because I completely
forgot in the last
question to mention it.
But, yeah, it's very related.
And I think what I love about
your question just now is you
asked about the communities.
And you use the word
"community" rather than "tool."
So I think a lot of
what we're seeing
is groups of artists coming
together and collaboratively
making tools or
methodologies or practices
between themselves, where
they're sharing bits of code
or different techniques.
P5 is one example, but
there's many others.
But I think your focus on
community is so right on
and what's really apparent
in the works of these artists
in the exhibition, too.
It's one thing to have an
open source piece of code that
might get shared or used.
And I think it's another to
build a space around that
and to be really intentional
about who is welcomed here.
How are we thinking
about using technology?
about collaboration?
How are we building structures
as a community towards a future
that is more
inclusive or that is
more supportive of artists
and the sorts of practices
we want to have?
So yeah, it's really exciting
to see a lot of the artists
in this exhibition
using open-source tools.
And the fact that these works
will also be open-source
means that others
can build on them.
And it can be part of
the ongoing conversation
and community.
Yes.
Although, as you point out, just
having the code out by itself
doesn't make a community
happen around it.
It can be an ingredient to that.
So in the open
source world, there's
a festival in Bergen,
Norway, called
Piksel, which is exclusively
for open-source artwork.
It's done with computing.
And so there are
these opportunities,
these communities,
that maybe aren't
tied to specific software
tools, platforms, works.
And then there's also
software tools that--
or platforms where people
sharing their work,
discussing it, coming up with
things is really important.
So there's a system,
Dwitter, which is really
like a very, very
lightweight addition
to JavaScript-- like a
few abbreviations of math
dot cosine and things like that.
As a technical feat,
it's not that great.
But what it's done is
it's enabled people
to make these concise
Tweet-length programs,
share them with each other, and
have conversations and build
community around there.
People do that with P5.js also.
But these are the aspects
that I find really intriguing.
So I'm wondering, Sarah,
from your perspective
if you have some sorts
of communities engaged
with generative art,
particularly maybe
the new ones that are
represented in the exhibit,
that you want to
highlight for us?
Yeah, and I think for
me what was so important
about this work
is, again, artists
who are playing with
language and decision-making.
And by including a lot
of people in an event
that requires
audience participation,
such as this show, you
really can create a dialogue
with a lot of different
perspectives, which
I found very interesting, which
I feel like was highlighted
in a lot of the work.
And having them all together--
it's almost like they're
having a dialogue
with one another.
I feel like that's
something that's
really important and
unique about this work,
compared to something that
is a unified material object.
It's something that
exists within a community
and is also continually
building off of each other.
But for me, the
dialogue is something
that's really
important, because we
need to have these critical
discussions, where we introduce
different ideas
through emergent form
to create alternative knowledge
in how we use computation.
Because it is-- it's
something that's
going to be consistently
evolving over time.
So generating new
narratives, like Fox
was mentioning all
these things, are
going to be really critical
in the future of art.
And I'm curious what
Fox has to say, too.
Sure, thanks, for
asking me, too.
So I can answer both
in terms of what
I see for communities, for
the artists in the exhibition,
and then maybe segue to
some of the communities
I feel engaged with
in my own work.
And so Nick earlier was talking
about communities oriented
around particular types
of software practices,
whether that's open source
software, free software,
and more.
At the same time
as when he spoke
about the different
artists themselves,
he alluded to other
types of communities,
such as where they're
situated within
different global communities.
And that might
include communities
related to issues like gender,
race/ethnicity, nationality,
and more.
And so one way that I
like to look at this as--
and I think it's
maybe common now
to think about intersections
between communities.
But usually, that's
more for the kind
of social-cultural communities.
Here, I think we're
looking at intersections
between those types
of communities
as well as different types
of software practices.
So for example, the
difference between
festival-oriented digital
media artists compared
to artists who are focused
in the gallery, the kind
of fine arts scene,
that has software arts
involved, but on the
periphery quite often.
And electronic literature
as another kind of example.
I know Nick is interested
in the demo scene
and other types of communities.
And so I like to
really think about how
all of those
communities intersect
and then how they
can be generative
when you think about
these kind of issues.
I'm thinking about work.
I collaborated with
Jason Lewis at Concordia
and other researchers
for a workshop
on indigenous protocols and
artificial intelligence.
And that's a kind of example of
communities of practice focused
on AI coming together
with communities that
are interested in indigeneityi.
And then just finally, I'll
just say about some of the way
that I think about communities.
I feel like there are
a lot of communities
I've been engaged with
in terms of AI practice
and mathematics, computer
science, digital media arts,
and fine arts and so forth.
And one of the reasons
I went into academia
is that there
weren't always places
where all of those
different constituencies
all came together naturally.
I think they're
increasingly more.
But still, they're
underrepresented.
And so Nick mentioned the
Imagination, Computation,
and Expression Laboratory.
I saw that as a place where
some of these kind of issues
could come together-- issues of
social and cultural analysis,
social change, algorithmic
representation, meaning
and semantic
representations, and more.
And now with the MIT Center
for Advanced Virtuality, that I
was founding director of,
started a couple of years ago,
here.
I look at that as just
another opportunity
to continue building these
kind of communities, where
you bring those
kind of interests
into intersection with one another.
So you can have people who
are interested in pushing
the boundaries of virtual
reality, augmented reality,
other forms of immersive
media, synthetic media,
but also looking at the
latest, say, race and gender
critical work and building
systems that embody
and model those kind of
phenomena within the same unit,
or access to education
in STEM, where
you look at
students' backgrounds
as positive resources for
learning and for social change.
So I just look at
this increasing path
towards bringing those
different concerns together
within the same
community, finding others
who are doing the same,
and then providing
the opportunities for
people here at MIT
and more broadly to
do that kind of work.
Yeah.
I think there's a wide range
of not just communities,
but also we can talk about
literal spaces in terms
of architectural spaces or the
way that events like festivals
facilitate types
of interactions.
I think it's important
not to forget about that,
as we are in our
different circumstances
today due to the public
health situation,
and to look forward
to how some of those
can be restored and improved.
Now, Fox came down to
Babycastles Community Gallery
in New York, which has
representation in the show,
and kicked us off for
the Synchrony Demo Party
down there--
this DIY basement space.
It's very different than the
spaces at MIT or at the Design
Media Arts Program at
UCLA, which is also
well-represented in the show.
So there's this range of
different opportunities
that people have to
connect with each other,
to learn from each other's
practices, to develop work.
And I'm just fascinated
by learning about some
of these that fit into
the smaller niches--
not just trying to
improve, for instance,
what we do at MIT and other
top research institutions.
Just in closing, I
do want to mention
that this conversation and
having this as a produced
video really was done explicitly
in order to foster community
and conversation, so
that during our opening,
instead of interrupting everyone
by having comments from me
and other people, we'd be
able to put this out, make
it available to you, hopefully.
I'd love you to be
able to full-screen it.
Turn on the closed captions and
watch it at two times speed,
so you can get
through it and all
download it into your brain,
if you like to do that.
And then come to
that conversation
that we're having, come to
the opening, and have exchange
and discussion
with other people.
Let me see if there's any
final remarks that any of you
have in the dwindling
seconds that we have, here.
I just wanted to
congratulate all the artists.
I know it's a hard
time to be making work.
And it's a really important time
to be making work and finding
some balance.
And I think all these artists
are doing that and opening up
really important questions here.
[00:36:39.74] That's a very
important thing to state,
Lauren.
I want to congratulate
the artists,
thank them for making the work
that people can experience
in their browsers,
and also making
it available as free/libre/
open-source software.
I know that's a part
of people's practice
that they called out in
their bios in some cases.
But whether or not they
started off that way,
everybody agreed to it.
And as a result, we do
have that contribution.
I would add just--
All right--
--in line with your--
I would add just in line
with your congratulations
of the artists, Lauren
and Nick, and just
to say that I also felt very
inspired by the kind of work
that the artists produced.
In all of the terms
we mentioned earlier,
but we also didn't speak
a lot about aesthetics.
And I just want
to say that there
is equally broad array of
aesthetic kind of sensibilities
in the work, from 3D CGI, which
is almost video game-like,
to more InfoVis work, to more
critical radical socially
engaged artwork, to glitch art.
And so I feel like there's
just such a wide array
of aesthetic sensibilities
that are represented,
along with the
social possibilities,
political possibilities,
along with the communities.
I just found that
really inspiring
to work with you, Sarah, Lauren,
and Nick and Parag on this,
and then, of course, just engage
with the work of these artists.
Yeah, it's well said.
And again, thank you
to all the artists.
And it's such an incredible
time to make work, and also
a very challenging time.
And it's important
that we continue
to make work that analyzes and
critiques these structures.
And thank you so much.
All right, and thanks
once again to you
three and to Parag for
the work on the jury
to figure out which of
the very large number
of good submissions
we had would be
able to end up in this
"Generative Unfoldings"
exhibit and the new work
that we'd be able to get.
All right, thanks much.
And we'll look forward
to the opening.